welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and black panther opened the mcu to
powerful themes in beautiful world
building with a broader spectrum of
colors
as i've been re-watching the infinity
saga i found a ton
of new visual details hidden throughout
black panther that we overlooked in past
reviews so let's take another look and
break everything down scene by scene the
film opens with the history of wakanda
which oscar-winning production designer
hannah beechler
displays via grains of vibranium like a
father molding these figures from
vibranium and rich soil with his hands
this is actually the same medium modern
wakandans use to tell their stories to
each other
and it all stems from this ancient
vibranium meteorite the big
what if that kicked off black panther's
afrofuturist alternate history the use
of monochromatic grains reflects the
universality of the story director ryan
coogler sneaks in this idea with the
opening words
baba yes my son tell me a story
which one the story of home now the
script labels these voices as an
anonymous father and son
but those voices are those of sterling k
brown and seth carr
jobu and his son njitaka future
killmonger the forgotten sons of wakanda
maintaining the legacy of their true
ancestral roots so this story is as much
killmongers as it is t'challa's
a debate between ideals how do we right
the wrongs of history
aggressive revolution or patient
outreach this forgiveness versus revenge
conflict was modeled on the debate
between civil rights leaders dr martin
luther king jr and malcolm x
as spike lee observed by including
quotes from both of those men
and do the right thing both of these
approaches are worthy of consideration
like all the titles in this movie
oakland begins in wakandan and
translates to english
the film as a whole translates the story
of wakanda to something we understand
and they base the wakandan written
alphabet on ins bidi
an ancient cuneiform from nigeria
t'chaka explains ulysses clause stolen
vibranium and age of ultron was actually
made possible by njobu
information leaked to him by zuri forest
whitaker's younger self played by denzel
whitaker he convincingly poses as
non-wakandan faking ignorance over
kneeling
i also like how he and njobu wear purple
and black here their home colors
in the present day as t'challa drops
from the ship he folds his arms in the
wakandan salute googler said that they
got this salute from egyptian pharaohs
and ancient west african sculptures
and the fact that it translates to hug
or love in american sign language
googler shows these militants with an
unbroken long take
something he does over and over again
throughout the film
to convey a scene's geography so that
after getting a lay of the land when he
later
intercuts with rapid fire action we
don't get disoriented t'challa nakia and
okoye are color-coded in black
green and red here oscar-winning costume
designer ruth e carter made them reflect
the colors of the pan-african flag
so that when the trio fights together in
battle they represent all corners of the
continent
when they return to wakanda the facade
is projected with these hexagonal tiles
which recur on shuri's 3d mapping to the
car and in her lab but balancing this
advanced tech are traditional african
architecture on the buildings like those
rondevels on the rooftops it's another
example of this idea of afrofuturism
afrofuturism is a concept embraced by
the later black panther comics the ones
authored by ta-nehisi coates
it's a blending of racial themes and
sci-fi to imagine an
idealized advanced future that still
embraces pieces of present-day culture
and from the moment we arrive in this
setting coogler gives us a little hint
of the magnetic train that runs
throughout the city and we keep seeing
this train
over and over again it's all to set up
the final fight as a return to a
familiar battlefield
queen ramona's dress was designed to
resemble a setting sun behind her for
the sun setting on her marriage as she's
in mourning here meanwhile her crown was
designed to stand tall from
every angle north east south and west
for all tribes of wakanda to see
sure he teases about his suit just
because something works doesn't mean
that it cannot be improved
a little hint of the deeper theme of
this movie that just because a system
works for some doesn't mean we shouldn't
work to improve it toward perfection for
all when sure he flips him off behind
ramona's back
t'challa's mouth drops and that is how
ramona knows what shuri did so that she
could scold her like her all-facing
crown
the queen has eyes everywhere but really
it's because she knows her children so
well like any great queen knows all of
her people we meet adult eric killmonger
as he steals vibranium and this mask
you're not telling me that's vibranium
too uh no i'm just feeling it
he's remembering the moment he as a kid
looked up at the wakandan ship in
oakland that royal ship is designed to
look like an african mask from below
so that commoners looking up at it will
be inspired with pride for their
homeland killmonger wears a similar mask
in the comics but here
it's a symbolic claim of his royal place
at warrior falls the tribes are color
coded and inspired by real african
tribes
the border tribe in blue are based on
farmers in lesotho who wear similar
blankets the river tribe wears green and
uses shells in their designs isaac de
bankele plays their leader and his lip
disc is a practice by the mercy tribe of
ethiopia the mining tribe wears red
based on the himba tribe of namibia
known for treating their hair with red
clay like this the merchant tribe wears
white with fancier finery and the royals
wear black and purple reflecting the
black vibranium grains
and the purple heart-shaped herb the two
sources of their power
zuri welcomes him prince t'challa
now the black panther prelude comic
confirms that t'challa has carried the
black panther role as his father's
champion
for nearly a decade at this point so
king isn't the same thing as black
panther so he's already black panther
this trial here is to legitimize his
succession
to the throne each tribe announces their
support including the river tribe
the river tribe will not challenge today
ibombe comes from the wakandan spoken
language of
hosa south african dialect spoken by
nelson mandela and yi bombay means to
hold or hold fast depending on how you
derive it and it should sound familiar
because t'challa later uses it as his
battle cry in infinity war
so this reframes that moment as a salute
to his love
baku arrives with the jabari mountain
tribe their iconography is the ape for
mbaku comics origin as the cannibalistic
man ape something they change for this
movie and they joke about later
one more word and i will feed you to my
children
i'm kidding we are vegetarians here he
says glory to hanuman
now the others worship the panther
goddess bast hanuman
is the monkey deity from hindu and
various other religions small detail i
love how winston duke commits to the
authentic pronunciation
putting his full chest and shoulders in
the of his name
baku briefly gets the upper hand in the
duel and t'challa sees his mother upside
down googler actually uses the same
framing on the throne later when
killmonger usurps it the overturning of
t'challa's kingdom is a fleeting fear
right now but killmonger makes it
reality in the second half of the film
so t'challa spares mbaku as they're
both on the edge of the falls a critical
move that ends up
saving t'challa giving him an alliance
that helps him revert and restore his
throne by the end of the film t'challa
visits his ancestors in the ancestral
plain based on djali and the comics and
his father t'chaka advises him
and it's hard for a good man to be king
it's a warning for t'challa's struggles
to govern but also
to protect his rule from less noble men
in the streets of wakanda new detail i
spotted behind nakia and t'challa
there's a starstruck local who uses her
kamoyo beads to snap a photo of the king
now i love this throne room it's set on
a leveled piece of rock from the
mountain below
so that these leaders now sit and
deliberate on the same surface that
their ancestors did
before this building was built up around
it but if you look closely at that
throne the vibranium has these
cross-hatched streaks in it these are
woodman statin patterns
and they appear from the cooling of the
iron nickel alloy that's found
in meteorites suggesting that this
throne was carved directly from
unrefined meteorite ore
and this whole from the ground up design
is also reflected in shuri's lab with
its
spiral staircase shaped like a giant
drill going into the rock the
sneakers that shuri gives them have
these wakandan lettering on them and
they translate to
air and t'chaka t'challa being t'chaka's
air but also it's a pun
calling these the wakandan air jordans
since they were inspired by the american
movie bob i used to watch referring to
the self-tying shoes from back to the
future part two and she gives t'challa
options for a new suit dispatching
necklace to the golden one he says
tempting but the idea is to not be
noticed this golden necklace is the one
that killmonger later takes
producing a helmet with gnashing teeth
and jaws reflecting killmonger's whole
aim to show off wakandan might
versus t'challa's quiet nature though he
remains
tempted to lash out with that kind of
revenge against killmonger on behalf of
wakabi the glowing stored energy in the
suit lights up
more wakandan lettering on the abdomen
that translates to i love you mom
so this text salutes both their father
and their mother look if the answers to
these mysteries feel just
out of your reach imagine if the content
you normally consume on the internet
actually was being blocked from your
reach even if you're paying to be a
subscriber or something but you just
have to live in the wrong country or if
you're worried about hackers or scammers
stealing your information there's all
kinds of things to worry about these
days well
expressvpn is your solution thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen
or tracked and can grant you access to
blocked content many websites and
services are blocked in different parts
of the world
and some countries censor websites and
don't let you surf freely
like netflix in the uk has content that
us netflix doesn't have and vice versa
there are countries that won't even let
you use netflix can you imagine
and some things are more expensive
online depending on where you live like
airline tickets
an industry that has no business raising
prices on us right now
you're finally at our mercy expressvpn
allows you to reroute your connection to
a server in a country of your choice
making
those geo restrictions a thing of the
past expressvpn is also helpful for
preventing your online data from being
stolen or monitored without your
knowledge
express vpn servers operate at the
fastest speeds they have 24 7 customer
support and it's super easy to use just
fire up the app and connect with just
one
click it's the top rated vpn provider
rated number one by techradar cnet and
many more
find out how you can get three months
free by clicking on the link in the
description box below
expressvpn.comrockstars again that's
expressvpn.comrockstars and busan bilbo
meets gollum
you got a mixtape coming out oh yeah
yeah actually there is one
yeah i'll send you the soundcloud link
if you like claws audio interests are a
nod to his new
sonic cannon replacing the arm that
ultron cut off it's a slightly more
practical version of his comics
abilities and have like a
satellite dish style arm cannon but also
he like can turn into sonic energy
himself and stan lee cameo is here in
the credits he's credited as thirsty
gambler
after complaining about wearing a wig
earlier okoye now
weaponizes it along with her purse and
down on the floor nakia also weaponizes
her femininity using her heel to beat a
guy and she'll spend the rest of the
sequence barefoot when claw dismantles
nakia and nikoi's car in the background
behind ross after he picks him up that
loose tire just keeps rolling and
rolling
and when claw fires at t'challa
t'challa's suit briefly peels back
readjusting later shuri explains that
the wakandan mining trains
sonic stabilizers sonic what in its raw
form
vibranium is too dangerous to be
transported at that speed so i
i developed a way to temporarily
deactivate it explaining how t'challa
knew
sonic energy would deactivate his and
killmonger suits
in the final fight killmonger bears out
claw when he shows up around his neck
his wakandan ring is
visible now we saw a similar ring in
civil war it's a little clue here for
his real identity which we're about to
learn and later when he usurps the
throne
that ring moves from the necklace to his
right hand
t'challa pulls a cap and jumps on the
grenade and that blast
charges up a suit with a purple glow
which gets brighter and brighter with
each of killmonger's shots until the
final blast
throws him back against the wall where
that purple shock wave is dispersed back
in wakanda shuri says
create another broken white boy for us
to fix referring of course to bucky from
that civil war post-credits scene and
this movie's post-credits scene where
bucky is mid-recovery and is now
nicknamed the white wolf a nod to hunter
in the comics killmonger shoots through
his girlfriend
linda shutting off all ties to his
american identity before returning to
his homeland but earlier linda's name
tag in the museum read
tilde and that's because she was
originally going to be tilda johnson
nightshade
but marvel tv cast gabrielle dennis as
tilda johnson and luke cage on netflix
here she was renamed linda and her role
was reduced and in the shootout claw
actually had a kill shot first but that
bullet ricocheted off killmonger's chest
armor sparing him allowing him to get
the drop on claw
zuri reveals the truth about t'chaka and
jobu's political ties
the leaders have been assassinated
communities flooded with drugs and
weapons they are overly policed
and incarcerated here right at the
midpoint of movie coogler reframes
killmonger's goals as somewhat justified
challenging the hero to consider that
vengeance in some cases
might be emotionally justified when the
two meet t'challa tells him
only reason i don't kill you where you
stan is because i know who you are
he thinks he's showing mercy but he just
gave killmonger everything he needs in
this royal dispute because
since t'challa knows killmonger's
kinship killmonger knows that he has to
honor his claim to the speedy trial
t'challa has removed his own ability to
possibly delay things with an
investigation
and when killmonger declares his
identity the music track underneath is
king's dead
it's a signal of this changing of power
as well as the overthrowing of
t'challa's mlk inspired values
at warrior falls killmonger breaks his
spear to make it better for stabbing
which is actually a tactic from
legendary african warrior
shakazulu who is famous for evolving
past spears
to give himself a tactical advantage
over other tribes and each time he cuts
t'challa with this oscar-winning
composer ludvig uranus and mixes in a
blow of the
fool of flute
this is the instrument he uses to
identify killmonger throughout the film
as opposed to the talking drum for
t'challa the talking drum beats like
crazy in the first half of this fight
but it goes silent in the second half
right as killmonger overtakes him
killmonger tosses t'challa over the
falls as he does in the comics and
killmonger's meditation shows his
younger self cradling his father
the same pose that t'challa made when he
cradled his dead father at the u.n
two young wakandans two parallel stories
jobu's diary includes entries in
wakandan with an alphabet key explaining
how killmonger learn the language
there's also a map to wakanda with
coordinates now if you put these actual
numbers into google earth they take you
to the northeastern part of the
democratic republic of congo near the
ugandan border
almost exactly the world map marker from
wakanda's first mcu shout out in iron
man 2.
killmonger burns the heart-shaped herb
garden showing its true agenda not to
preserve wakanda or make it better but
to strip it of its uniqueness to make it
like the rest of the world and the rest
of the world like wakanda ramonda shuri
and nakia fleet
mbaku his throne room is lined with
these birch trunks and they were chosen
because birch grows in northern climates
they're in the mountains here also
notice how it's sharpened to intimidate
the visitors t'challa's resurrected and
he confronts his father about his
abandonment of his nephew
he was the truth i chose to omit we're
back to the debate over how to settle
the sins of history however it's
addressed it cannot go ignored like
langston hughes's dream deferred
it festers like a sore or it sags like a
heavy load or even in some cases
explodes as it did with their forgotten
kin killmonger makes his attack plan
but the war dogs in london new york and
hong kong are standing by
new york hong kong and london are the
three power centers with sanctums
killmonger's attack would have come at a
very inconvenient time for the sorcerers
who actually came under assault
just a few months after this in the mcu
chronology technically
down on the train tracks the two fight
t'challa claws to swing around
there's a move that's a bit similar to
wolverine's clawing to swing around in
the statue of liberty an
x-men t'challa ends up defeating
killmonger by using his knowledge about
the magnetic train tracks giving him
just enough of a window
to stab killmonger with the same
shockazulu spearhead
that killmonger created before this is a
total home field advantage
it's a trick that killmonger couldn't
possibly see coming because he was
robbed of his opportunity to grow up in
this homeland so as t'challa did with
zemo in civil war
he lets forgiveness prevail and allows
killmonger a chance to see the wakandan
sunset that his father used to tell him
about in bedtime stories
earlier killmonger promised the sun will
never set on the wakandan empire
here the sun sets on his dreams and the
strings of girenson's ancestral plane
theme return here
[Music]
signaling killmonger's union with his
ancestors in this moment when t'challa
learned the truth earlier he was most
disgusted with his father's actions with
his brother
so he does his best to do that for his
cousin here but killmonger
stays true to himself just bury me in
the ocean
with my ancestors that jump from the
ships
because they knew death was better than
bondage
those chilling final words stay with
t'challa the final minutes reveal that
he opens his council to the jabari tribe
baku has joined the chat
and the movie's original final scene
which was shifted to the post-credits
scene shows t'challa speaking to the u.n
the wise built bridges while the footage
built barriers similar to the advanced
aliens the asgardians building their
bifrost bridge to share their protection
to other peoples
wakanda now opens its doors even when as
we'll see in infinity war that will cost
them a lot
coogler instead made this movie's final
scene more personal or returned to his
hometown of oakland where the old
makeshift hoop out of the crate has been
improved with a real one
as t'challa plans to enrich this
community with an international outreach
center the cautious
isolationist at the beginning of the
movie never would have opened up his
outlook like this
without challengers like nakia and
killmonger and the kid he focuses on
here is played by alex hibbert from
moonlight a child full of potential
an upward looking dreamer just like
t'challa's cousin once was
yeah you know he wants to respond with a
stark style i am black panther but he
doesn't need to because now this kid
will have the chances that killmonger
never had as a kid
to reach up as implied by kendrick lamar
and sissy's credits music
all the stars are closer to the stars
that blessed all of them with a history
they can all now
share in follow me on instagram and
twitter for takes too hot for youtube
follow new rockstars and hit that
subscribe button so you don't
accidentally miss out on our next mcu
breakdown
like a dusted dope you should have gone
for the head
[Music]
you